[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello i'm brian wood technical
communications and outreach manager at
wolfram
i'm here today with leo laguna ruiz a
software engineer for wolfram system
modeler
how are you today leo hello i'm fine
thank you
thank you excellent leo's going to talk
a little bit about how he uses system
modeler
to model analog audio synthesizers
um which some some musicians out there
might recognize
more colloquially as uh just a synth um
so why don't we start off with just a
little bit of background for anyone
who may not be into music or may not
really have heard of this before
uh what exactly do you mean when you say
analog synthesizer
well er so in no
we know that that music and sound is is
produced by waves right
so in the 70s or early 60s
uh the people start started designing
these new electric circuits in order to
to
try to replicate the sounds and
the way they were they were approaching
it it was by creating
the synthesizers which i i
like to see as analog computers because
you have
like oscillators that generate waveforms
filters uh amplifiers in order to
control the
the the level of the of the of these
waveforms and combining all this
it was possible to generate sounds
that in the beginning try to imitate
existing sounds but
it ended up creating a new a whole new
category of sounds that that we never
hear before and all that equipment from
the 70s and
up to the 80s it was it was an analog
electronics
right so that's uh so
basically it's sending an electrical
signal through
and sort of just manipulating it to
to become something you know something
that's been altered and then
creating a sound out of that so i like
the way you say that yeah it's it's like
an analog
computer because you're sort of just um
it's
you're not computing something
explicitly
it's just that the electronics
themselves are actually
sort of doing those processes and and
manipulating
it themselves um so where
where would most people have heard uh a
synthesizer i mean what kinds of
places would people my might people
recognize this from
yeah i mean probably nowaday if you have
listened
any song released in the last uh
20 years you have hear a synthesizer
but there are a few songs that have like
a like a very recognizable synthesizer
sound
for example just coming to my mind daft
punk
they use a lot of synthesizers uh or
samples of synthesizers so
they they they produce electronic music
and and mostly the sounds are
synthesized
but yeah nowadays i guess that every
song has
some part that is synthesized or that is
processed using some kind of
digital signal processing right right
yeah and i think that that's something
um
a lot of people probably don't realize
about the music that they hear is that
uh
a lot of those sounds are either
entirely sort of uh
made up like like they are not uh
an actual sound that's made by you know
hitting things together or anything like
that
um and and that's the parts that aren't
entirely made up are
uh fairly heavily processed in a lot of
cases so
um so what tell us a little bit about
what it is that you're doing
with uh with system modeler
scenarios and one
since many many years back i i've been
interested in music technology in in
that same role
lead me to to study electrical
engineering
and that lead me to to start
to get interested in simulations and
creating models
and that's how i ended up working in
system modeler
because i really like the simulations
and creating mathematical models
right and at some points since
music has always been a like passion for
me
i i started trying to combine these
these two things like
okay i'm going to use the product that
i'm developing to do something
interesting
and at the same time testing yeah yeah
absolutely
so uh so you're building these you're
essentially just
modeling the the circuits that
make up an analog synthesizer is that
right
right so the one one nice characteristic
of the
analog synthesizers is that
i mean here i'm comparing them with with
the
digital purely digital versions the
analog synthesizers
since they're made with transistors
operational amplifiers all these
components
are a bit imperfect and that
imperfection
it affects a lot the the resulting sound
so if if i make exactly the same
going back to the analogy of the of the
analog computer
versus a digital computer so nowadays if
you want precision in your calculations
you
will use a digital computer you are not
going to use an analog computer right
right but what ha but in in sound it's a
little bit different because
the analog computers had these
imperfections that that shape the sound
that
changed how the the sound work and
and it just and it is more appealing for
for uh well for musicians yeah yeah
and also people i mean so that's how i
got interested in into trying to
understand
how how these circuits work and once i
understood how how the circuit works
uh i started creating digital versions
that tried to
to imitate that sound without losing
losing uh the nice characteristics
in the transition to digital right yeah
and that's uh
kind of a unicorn i think in the uh in
the audio world because there's this
there's that back and forth between you
know digital versus analog
audio and there's the the sort of
psychoacoustics that
effects that you're talking about where
there are maybe some
imperfections in the analog audio that
people actually prefer
um so it's it is kind of a uh a really
unique thing to be able to
take that analog version and turn it
into a digital thing that still
maintains those those sort of
imperfections
um right so um why don't we why don't we
take a look
uh i know you've got a couple of things
that you can show us here um
and in particular i was kind of curious
to see
what kind of what your workflow looks
like within system modeler so why don't
you once you go ahead and show us your
notebook that you've got here
so within system modeler what i usually
do is
is like taking a schematic or or even my
own designs
and inside system motor i started
creating like my own library of
components
that that model the the components that
i was using
and then it was very easy to just put
them together and start running
simulations to see how
my models sound compared to the to to
the analog version
so and once i i get like this simulation
model which is
efficient because that's that's a very
very important thing
the model not only needs to be uh
good sounding good but it also needs to
be efficient
so that means that sometimes i have to
drop the complexity of
of the of the components like in the
case of an operational amplifier
which consists of many transistors
i can probably model it in a in a
simpler way that
that keeps the characteristics that that
are important to the sound so with
system motor i can
change the level of modeling it started
with a with a very complex model
and then making experiments for example
what
what what will happen if i make a
simpler model
because it still sounds good and if it
sounds good
it will be more efficient and then i can
start like dropping dropping dropping
the
the level of detail in order to find
like this perfect sweet spot which
in which you have a model that sounds
good and it's also
efficient
and that that's part of the of the work
that i do with system modular uh
and once once i have like a model that
works
i use mathematica to to extract these
equations because
as you can see here this is like a this
is a graphical
model at this point i'm doing i'm still
following the abstractions of
electronics right and then i can use
mathematica to
get all the equations of this system and
start doing more manipulations
on those equations in order to to to
optimize the the system
and trying to perform the minimal set of
computations necessary
in order to to simulate it
and and that's uh that's like a a
loop that i that i have to do in order
to to get
right the simplest system that
reproduces
the the original the original sound
and yeah once once i have this reduced
set of equations
i i implement those those equations in
in a in a
dsp language that i that i design
which generates c plus plus code
that i can simply compile into a
traditional
audio plugin cool
very interesting so so it seems like
that would almost be useful for um
for sort of creating uh simpler versions
of of the actual
and the actual physical things too like
you could
sort of simplify that model and then uh
you know instead of have to build up the
original
thing you sort of have uh fewer fewer
pieces maybe that you can
i mean does that do do you do that with
with hardware as well
yeah they actually do and so what
happens is that
when you are dropping level of detail
probably
uh it is happened to me before that i'm
dropping level of detail and then i find
something that sounds different but
still sounds very good i mean it is not
bad by all
by any means right and and sometimes
i've just released like
alternative versions of the same of the
same circuit
uh that that maybe do not have all the
characteristics but they are
still very good as sound generators
and probably more more efficient so yeah
and it helps me to
to fix the
the mistakes well i don't want to call
it mistake because
they are not right but the limitations
of of uh
of a circuit sure okay
because for me it's very easy just to
change a component in the schematic and
then just rerun
the whole processing right yeah rather
than having to you know
re-solder and switch things around and
sure
yeah that makes a lot of sense um so so
it seems like
you use kind of both system modeler and
wool from language
um like you said as a sort of back and
forth
uh before finalizing these projects
uh can can you talk just a little bit
about like the features that make that
possible because i know that this is
the integration between those two has
been sort of built up
over the last couple years so yeah that
that's the the biggest
advantage if if you take like any other
simulator
or a traditional simulator using for
electrical circuits
once you have your simulation circuit
it's very hard to
get the equations from it
and and we call for language and system
model this integration is just one
command and i get like
a list of hundreds of equations and and
then i can easily reduce them to
to uh to a dozen or less less equations
so yeah that that
that would i would say that is that the
biggest feature being able of
of taking a graphical graphical model
where i didn't have to deal with any
equations and just immediately
translating it into
into equations that i can still
manipulate
right so you can you've got the sort of
the modeling and then the analysis
built into the same workflow so you
don't have to switch between systems and
stuff like that yes
very nice very nice um so why don't we
when we go ahead and
um i understand you've got at least a
quick sample for us that you can show
to kind of kind of give people an idea
of the kinds of things that you might
build with this system
yes i should have something here so
this is a this is a short video that
that i made
using the modules that i that i create
and the idea with this uh patch it was
to create something ambient
that a it consi
it considers randomness it integrates
random randomness and chaos
in order to generate the music so what i
did is is
just setting the rules of the sound but
the
the sound is being generated randomly
i'm gonna play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so i i really like this example um
because of that that randomness like
you're talking about it's like every
every time you think you know what it's
doing it sort of morphs and changes just
a little bit
that's so this this is the the kind of
thing that someone might hear
uh for instance maybe in the in the
background of a movie or something where
it's very
ambient and it gives you kind of a mood
but without really adding melody
right and i can stop it because one of
the nice things about this is that it
can last forever
sure yeah yeah and it's gonna be
constantly evolving yeah and and it's
uh sort of a a different experience
every time right like
every time you go through that process
it's gonna give you a slightly different
result and
it'll it'll sort of morph in slightly
different ways so that's uh
yeah that to me is really interesting
and stuff um
excellent well um this this has been a
really great chat
um it's to me a an excellent example
of that kind of blend of technical
knowledge and creativity that we really
like to see
at wolfram um so if anyone
if anyone's interested in what leo's
doing here you can go to
uh volt dsp that's v
u l t dsp.com
uh check out some of his work uh and you
mentioned that this
vcv rack is something that you do you
use
um and uh actually you you could go
ahead and show
uh your website if you don't mind yeah i
actually
have it here
[Music]
this is the website and here you will
find the the software that i make
also the programming language that i
developed for the dsp
and also like some of the hardware that
i make
because at the end all these models
that that i make of analog synthesizers
specifically for filters i can
bring them back to the hardware world so
i spend a lot of time turning
these electrical circuits into
mathematical models to have them in
software
but then then i will i will put them
back into a
into a convenient package which will be
a like one of the a filter
yeah so this is a i should have a
picture
here okay so this one is it's a
it's a hardware module that is fully
digital but it emulates
many different filters so all these
models
that i have developed they they run
inside that one and it's very convenient
just to
loop around them and find the one that
you like
wow yeah yeah that's an impressive
amount of
options on on just a very small package
interesting so uh so you've got software
and hardware then
that basically uh everything that you've
sort of built
and uh developed and modeled uh through
this process
right right cool so um anyone
anyone interested like i said uh volt
dsp.com
um and again uh we had didn't really
get a chance to go through it but uh vcv
rack is is the tool that you're using
for uh
for for testing these is that right
what exactly is it i mean is the main
the main tool i used to
to test and develop and also to
distribute
if you download the ecb rack you can
find
for free like most of the of the modules
that i have made
and the ones that i use in in the in the
demo before
right on so uh vcbrack.com you can you
can check that out
and uh anyone who's interested in doing
what leo has done
obviously you can you can go to
wolfram.com find out more about
system modeler and wolfram language you
get
that full modeling analysis workflow
like leo was talking about
and um i think uh
i think that's all we've got today so uh
thanks a lot for talking with me leo
no thank you thank you thanks for
joining us
you can check out other wolfram tech
talks live coding streams and more
on the wolfram research youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you